Abbi!
[ Both laugh ]
Man, I got you again!
Every time, man.
Come on, girl.
Bring it in.
Together: Hmm.
Uh...
Together: Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Hoo!
Doo, doo, doo.
Pshh!
-Aah!
[ Both laugh ]
So, what you
looking for, Abb?
Okay, so, this is
a little bit embarrassing,
but my building's
pre-World War I
in the plumbing,
and it's, like, really --
Shh.
[ Chuckles ]
Say no more.
Bath accessories.
Dope, dude, thanks.
Great seeing you.
You too.
Holla at me, Abb!
[ Cellphone vibrates ]
Hey, dude, I'm in
the middle of trying to find
this thing at BB&B.
Hold up,
you're at BB&B, Abbi?
Can you grab me
six power strips
and six extension cords
and meet me at that place
where that dude gave you
that condom stat?
Well, I was gonna
say stuff, too.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Holy shit bucket.
♪♪
Dude, what is
all of this?
Welcome to SheWork.
We officially open
for shiz-ness.
What is SheWork?
SheWork is
an inclusive work environment
that caters to smokers.
I see a bunch of --
no offense --
trash furniture and two people
smoking cigarettes.
Walk with me.
So, SheWork uses
the urban landscape for
a fast-paced work space
with no boundaries.
Huh.
If parkour is using the city
as your gym, SheWork is using
the city as your office.
So, correct me
if I'm wrong.
People are paying you
to use the free
public charging stations?
So what? All the great
male entrepreneurs do it, okay?
They take something
that already exists,
claim it was their idea,
throw in some fancy furniture,
and charge double for it.
For letting people
sit on your junk and smoke?
Exactly.
Wait, Ilana, hold on,
hold on, hold on.
I'm -- I'm sorry.
Smoking cigarettes
is disgusting.
Okay, smoking
is obvs heinous --
[ Coughs ]
But who am I to judge
a nicotine addiction?
I mean, I'm...fully
addicted to weed.
True.
Okay, you got the stuff.
I thank you, bitch.
Oh, yeah.
Come on. Come on.
Great,
thank you so much.
And, actually,
a trash can is the only thing
we don't need here
at SheWork.
No, no, no.
This is actually mine,
uh, my shit bucket,
so...
Come again?
It-- It's my shit bucket.
Pardon me?
My -- I had to get
a shit bucket.
[ Sighs ]
Okay, um...
Who, what, how, when,
where, and why?
Okay, it's a funny story.
Uh, you know how my toilet is
always getting clogged.
Pfft. [ Laughs ]
Yeah.
Um, so, Fernando actually
let me know that I can't
flush toilet paper anymore,
and actually I have to
discard it in a separate bin
right next to the toilet.
So what'd you say
to him?
So, then I said --
I said...
I said, "Fernando,
I will get that shit bucket."
That's what I said,
and I got -- I got one.
Oh, Abbi.
Dude, I was, like --
I was standing there,
and I was just,
like, so stunned by
what was going on,
I got bullied into
buying a shit bucket.
You know, and I think
we should take this issue
into the community-action
wing of SheWork.
Oh, wow, is there
whole other...?
Come on.
Okay.
Oh.
So, we have to review
our resources.
Okay.
[ Gasps ]
The printer/scanner.
So, there's
a scanning function.
What you're gonna do is scan
your tits, or your ass.
Make a shit ton
of copies.
Disseminate them to
all your neighbors --
but get this --
anonymously.
Everybody's like,
"What's going on?
Whose tits are these?
Meanwhile, you've
planted a stack of the tits
in Fernando's office,
and you pipe up, and you say,
"You know, I-I think it
might be Fernando,
and while we're on the topic,
why are we shitting in buckets?"
SheWork -- boosh!
Dude, you are
so close on that.
Okay, what if I print out
a petition, okay?
Uh-huh.
I got around to my neighbors,
and I'm like, "Guys,
this is an important issue.
We shouldn't be shitting
in shit buckets, okay?"
I get the full
signed petition,
take it back to Fernando,
and I'm like,
"Majority rules, man.
Change is coming."
Ooh, you are full-blown
grassroots.
You are the
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
of Astoria.
You're the Jewish
Shirley Chisholm of toilets.
Yes, I am gonna shit
in my toilet and flush.
Yes. Go get your bucket
and take care of your shit.
Come on.
[ Chuckles ]
Take care of your shit.
I love you, Abb.
Ah, and I love SheWork.
Miss, hi.
Are you sick of being
treated like a filthy outsider
at work because of your
tragic smoking habit?
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Mm.
How's that Wi-Fi
working out, L?
Ha, ha. Charging Station-Guest
is coming in clear as day.
You know, we are growing
rapidly, and I'm starting to
have to focus on expansion,
so would you feel comfortable
watching the fort?
[ Chuckles ]
Would I?
No, I-I was asking...
♪♪
[ Door closes ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
Hello, um, my name is
Abbi Abrams, and --
I don't want to buy
any Girl Scout Cookies.
No, no, no.
I-I'm not a Girl Scout anymore.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm a grown --
I-I'm actually
your neighbor.
I'm just going around
letting everyone know
that I'm having a tenant meeting
today in the lobby --
I have lived in this
building for 31 years,
and I've never seen you.
Well...
Wait, are you
Melody's roommate?
You know Melody?
Yes.
She dates that
wonderful young man
who always brings me
delicious cheeses.
That's, um --
That's Bevers.
They're the loveliest.
I love them, as well.